en los vídeos pasados ya empezamos a
platicar de cómo se puede financiar una
empresa ya sea con capital o bien con
deuda para financiarse con capital tenía
que emitir acciones de modo que los
inversionistas se volvieran dueños de la
empresa y para financiarse con deuda
tenía que emitir bonos o pagarés para
después pagar intereses
después de esto empezamos a platicar un
poquito acerca de la posibilidad de que
la empresa cayera en bancarrota y te
deje una pregunta pendiente lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es explorar
esto de la bancarrota y responder esa
pregunta para eso vamos a empezar
dibujando la hoja de balance de una
empresa entonces aquí al lado izquierdo
es el activo por aquí abajito tenemos el
capital más o menos algo así
y finalmente aquí tenemos un rectángulo
que es el pasivo que es la deuda va
entonces déjame ser un poco más concreto
y le voy a poner valores específicos a
este activo al pasivo y al capital
supongamos que acá tiene 10 millones en
activo 10 millones en activo este activo
pueden ser casas o coches o una cartera
de clientes muy buena o un sitio de
internet ya platicamos de varias de
estas cosas vamos a ponerle que acá
arriba la deuda es de 6 millones y por
tanto el capital debe de ser lo que
falta para completar el activo verdad
porque pasivo más capital es igual
activo entonces el capital debe de ser
de 4 millones este capital ya platicamos
cómo lo pudo haber obtenido ya dijimos
que pudo haber sido capital privado lo
va a poner así privado o bien que pudo
haber sido
público
público para poner su acento entonces
puede ser capital privado o público el
privado pues platicamos un poco de
capitalistas de riesgo de cuando
estábamos empezando la empresa y para el
público hablamos de una oferta pública
primaria y de cómo entramos a la bolsa
de valores luego empezamos a hablar un
poco de financiamiento con deuda y
dijimos lo siguiente bueno en realidad
aquí para todo el pasivos y aquí voy a
poner una p de pasivo en realidad podría
haber otro tipo de pasivos además de
deuda podríamos tener una demanda o algo
así pero ahorita como sólo nos importa
el financiamiento pensamos que todo esto
es pasivo de acá es pura deuda entonces
la forma en la cual se obtenía esta
deuda era o bien con un gran préstamo
bancario o viene metiendo varios bonos y
esos bonos pues le decíamos a las
personas que lo compraran para que
después les pagáramos intereses bueno
esta es la situación en donde vamos pero
ahora sí vamos a contemplar la situación
de que la empresa caiga en bancarrota
entonces déjame ponerle por acá arriba
bancarrota
banca rota y hay dos tipos de bancarrota
quizás debería ser un poco más
específico después no mejor ahorita hay
dos tipos de bancarrota en los cuales se
puede caer uno es por liquidación
liquidación
y el otro tipo de bancarrota es por
reestructuración
aquí también liquidación va entonces
liquidación y reestructuración
liquidación se trata básicamente de que
la empresa ya no sirve para nada y va a
poner que este es el activo que su
activo ya no funciona ya no tiene
sentido operar este negocio entonces ya
la empresa tiene que cerrar se vende
todo activo y con lo que se obtiene de
ese activo que se vendió se paga la
deuda y a estas personas del capital la
reestructuración es un poco distinta a
la reestructuración es que el activo
sigue funcionando que la empresa pues
todavía tiene un objetivo en la vida que
todavía funciona y entonces el chiste es
que como tiene muchísima deuda tiene que
reestructurar su lado derecho de la hoja
de balance para poder seguir funcionando
déjame ponerte unos numeritos que son
importantes a esta liquidación también
se le conoce bancarrota del capítulo 7 y
esta de acá se le conoce como bancarrota
del capítulo 11 porque son estos números
con los que se le conoce en eeuu y
entonces puedes pues frecuentemente ver
que en eeuu tal empresa cayó en
bancarrota del capítulo 7 o de capítulo
ahorita lo que quiero hacer es enfocarme
únicamente a la bancarrota de
liquidación y de cómo funciona esto de
que se venda el activo y de que se pague
la deuda vale entonces otra vez déjame
plantearte la situación supongamos que
tenemos una empresa de pues sigamos con
esta empresa de ventas de calcetines por
internet y supongamos que de repente la
gente deja de comprar calcetines en el
mundo así ya pasaron de moda allá nada a
nadie le importan los calcetines y
entonces no tiene nada de sentido tener
una empresa que venda calcetines y mucho
menos por internet entonces como no
tiene sentido que esta empresa sigue que
siga existiendo todo esto de acá se va o
sea todo esto ya no nos va a funcionar
todo este activo se va a devaluar
muchísimo por ejemplo en nuestra página
ya no va a servir de nada los calcetines
en bodega tampoco entonces todo está
activo como ya no va a servir de nada o
bueno va a servir de muy poquito lo
vamos a tener que vender pero no lo
vamos a poder vender a todo este precio
no lo vamos a poder vender a los 10
millones de este modo no sé supongamos
que que ya la empresa quiebra de
borrarle por aquí y algo de este estilo
más o menos algo así y que logramos
vender el activo pero no en los 10
millones que vale si no nada más en 5
millones 5 millones y la pregunta la
pregunta que te dice en el vídeo pasado
y que ahorita voy a retomar es quiénes
crees que obtienen primero su dinero si
lo pensaste un poquito o bien si te das
cuenta donde dejé el cacho de activo
pues la respuesta es de los primeros a
los que se les paga son a los
prestamistas a los que financiaron a la
empresa con deuda va entonces en
realidad vamos a tener que pagar las
cosas de abajo hacia arriba perdón de a
o sea bueno de arriba hacia abajo pero
más bien de abajo hacia arriba tiene un
mayor por prioridad más prioridad
y de esta forma primero se les paga a
los de arriba y luego a los de abajo
pero incluso dentro de los de deuda hay
algunos que tienen preferencias sobre
otros déjame indicarlo por acá con unas
separaciones
entonces voy a poner una flechita para
platicar un poco acerca de distintos
prestamistas hay unos que se llaman los
asegurados preferenciales asegurados
y preferenciales
hay otros que se llaman los asegurados
no preferenciales y finalmente hay unos
de menor jerarquía
a menor jerarquía
jerarquía entonces dentro de estos de
deuda a los primeros que se les paga son
a los asegurados preferenciales y por
qué porque cuando ellos hicieron su
préstamo lo aseguraron con algún bien de
la empresa por ejemplo un banco pudo
haber dicho bueno te presto pero si caes
en bancarrota cuando se venda la fábrica
es mía entonces la empresa está de
acuerdo a la firma y además él como es
preferencial y digamos
porque pagan o sea le presta una menor
tasa o algo así entonces además él es al
primero al que se le va a pagar entonces
se le paga este de acá luego se le paga
al asegurado no preferencial como
también está asegurado también hay
algunos bienes digamos coches o lo que
sea que se venden para poder pagarle a
él y finalmente de lo que queda se le
paga a los de menor jerarquía si se
acaba el dinero si se acaba el dinero ya
no le va a tocar nada a estos de acá
abajo déjame poner algunos numeritos
para para que veamos más o menos cómo
podría hacer esto voy a ponerle que los
asegurados preferenciales pues tienen
una
una deuda de un millón no sé hay que
pagarles un millón a caso de tres
millones y acá de dos millones por decir
algo entonces la dinámica es le pagamos
a los asegurados preferenciales de estos
cinco millones entonces si se alcanza
luego le pagamos a los asegurados no
preferenciales lo cual también alcanza
porque ahí van cuatro pero ahora nada
más quedan dos millones ahora quedan dos
millones de deudas pero nada más queda
un millón para repartir y entonces ese
millón se les reparte a estos a cada
quien le toca la mitad de lo que había
prestado va y te hace estar preguntando
bueno pero porque esto les fue tan mal
en realidad no les fue tan mal esto se
compensa por la siguiente razón en
realidad estos de menor jerarquía
durante todo el préstamo estuvieron
recibiendo una mayor tasa de interés de
interés
lo cual tiene sentido porque corrían el
riesgo de que tuviéramos una bancarrota
y de que ya no se les pagara
completamente y estos como son
preferenciales o bien están asegurados
tienen una garantía en algo entonces
prestan a menor interés interés porque
hay menos riesgo entonces aquí más o
menos se compensan las cosas pero
observa aquí se acaba el dinero y luego
qué sucede con los dueños del capital
pues los dueños del capital ya no
reciben nada reciben cero pesos lo cual
tiene sentido verdad esta es la
situación mala lo cual tiene sentido
porque ellos son los principales
apostadores en esta situación o sea si
le va mal a la empresa no reciben nada
pero si le iba bien pudieron haber
obtenido pues digamos diez veces su
dinero o tal vez mil veces su dinero les
podría haber ido muy bien y por tanto
tiene sentido que también les vaya mal
ahora no les está yendo tan mal esto de
cero pesos también quiere decir que no
tienen que pagar nada de esta deuda que
falta
antes en el pasado cuando no existía
este concepto de la responsabilidad
limitada cuando los dueños de una
empresa éste no podían pagar la deuda
que faltaba porque la bancarrota había
acabado a la empresa entonces ellos eran
los responsables si no podían pagar los
metían a la cárcel y tenían que ir algo
así como una prisión de deudores lo cual
era muy feo entonces ahorita la
estructura corporativa ayuda un poco a
que para que no sea tan tan catastrófica
la situación va
bueno esa es una situación más o menos
mala para ellos pero qué hubiera
sucedido si tuviéramos tantito más osea
si está activo si hubiera podido vender
digamos en dos millones de pesos más
partes entonces vamos a volver a hacer
las cuentas a ver qué pasa vamos a
ponerlo con color naranja este millón si
se pagaba estos tres millones también se
pagaban en ese orden luego estos dos
millones también se pagaban porque hasta
iban seis y tenemos siete y luego este
millón que sobra un millón que sobra se
reparte entre estos de acá entre los
entre los dueños del capital de esta
forma pues si reciben tantito pero
después son los últimos en recibir vale
bueno de eso se trata la bancarrota de
liquidación básicamente consiste en que
una empresa ya no tiene sentido que
opere entonces todos activos se tiene
que vender para pagarle a las personas
que le debe dinero y este pago se hace
con cierta jerarquía en donde los de la
deuda tienen más prioridad que sobre
sobre los dueños del capital y dentro de
la deuda y dentro del capital hay unas
subcategorías que tienen más jerarquía
que otras eso es bancarrota por
liquidación en el siguiente vídeo vamos
a platicar qué sucede si una empresa
pues todavía puede funcionar sin embargo
tiene tanta tanta deuda que ya sus
intereses se la comieron y tiene que
caer en una reestructuración de su lado
derecho de la hoja de balance bueno nos
vemos hasta la próxima